why crisp I'm not a white [ __ ] it's
crispy hi I'm Chloe and I'm from Great
Britain hi I'm Joyce and I am from
America I'm a fella I'm from Cambridge
England I'm Emily and I'm American have
you ever had British knives before
no but I have watched a lot of British
television oh that's the same thing
and I've always wanted to go to the pub
at 16 oh that was my biggest dream in
life I think what I miss the most about
my English necks it's just that they
don't really make sense to other people
who are like outside of that culture I
am so excited to show you because they
are so good oh yeah so these are walkers
prawn cocktail crisps
okay chips crisps we have a classic here
these are salt and vinegar potato chips
they got tang they make you sweat
sometimes they make you sweat yeah these
are really good like a sandwich okay or
something you think some of my bag
walkers I guess it looks like Lay's as
it is a minute so they're the same
company but they're just different names
and different comes of countries they
just have a really good kick but you
can't eat too many of them it's really
strong right kind of zaps your tastebuds
a little bit looks like delicious cuz
saw ins vinegar it's too tart for me but
this is like perfect
so these definitely don't taste like
what I know shrimp cocktail it tastes
like which i think is good but this
tastes a little bit like ketchup
it's like ketchup chips but I have one I
really want them please delicious and we
tried some crazy stuff together kids
what do you think even a Jew I'm biased
I still prefer those I think I prefer
these two all right thanks max these are
my all-time favorite snack ever I
freaking love these whenever my mom
comes to say I have to make her bring
like big bags of them she is it's are
incredible these are truly the most like
a dick
snap if you eat one cheese it and you're
done you scare me I like to eat them
like a little bunny this is dense this
is a heavy little bag no sound like
bunny food though yeah can she don't say
that that better look not very happy
with this box of cheez-its
I do like them I live as much as that
but they all like pretty comparable Z's
and more salty they like to have more of
a Tang whereas they aren't a soul to you
but they have a strong cheese taste so
this is not anything like a bunny I
can't be the only one who does it for
you there's more of them right i 100%
dozen each other I can't leave them
alone and they only have pound I think
the cheese it's way better than that
sorry Jacob's arrow is like a classic
English chocolate like everyone knows
what arrow is so arrows are little
bubbles in chocolate and you take a bite
like you'll feel the bubbles inside of
your mouth they also do a mint version
which is amazing like oh my god if you
ask yeah I do prefer this way more than
urges there's a hard chocolate shell but
as soon as you make contact with it it's
weird but I'm into it
so I have like a whole speech about
America let's hear it lemon oh it just
doesn't taste real where's like this
it's like light and fluffy and airy and
it was just a dream to eat the flavors
way more creamier it's absolutely
delicious
cool yeah we like arrow a lot better
arrow
yeah Capra son ya rabbina what is this
this is great
it's just like the Australians in there
like detergent cleaner juice thing why
is what this packaging Australia if I
saw this I'd wash my dishes with this
okay
verbena is black currants which I don't
know that you have black coming soon
it's like a blackberry blueberry that's
what it looks like there's no way of
describing this other than it's like
taste purple there are a few things in
America we're fighting for and the one
thing that's for sure is that Capri Sun
is the greatest kid strength in the
whole entire world I'm intrigued by the
water okay so it's a concentrate and so
you have to put it in water she chickens
oh is that the color that you usually go
for I like oh yeah this is the this
might even be a tea sweet of me passing
me but some people would like to drink
is that was like just this year but I
think that's awful thank you smells like
grape juice you know it's refreshing
[Music]
right mm-hmm this is very light even but
more concentrating then I think I might
just so I can see what black currant
actually it's interesting how people
make like home drinks in America we're
so used to powders and then I feel like
everywhere in Europe it's all liquid
when I first came to America in school
the kool-aid thing I was like what yeah
powder in water never myself a wing make
a cocktail
I actually like both of them a training
opportunity still they really do little
things it's like wine for kid yeah I
think so too I have my childhood
memories with Capri Sun but that's just
I mean it's just better so this is fun
yeah right yeah
I learned that England has a lot of cool
fun words for things I still don't know
what a black currant is but I know now
that it exists this was just lovely
still light folksy like oh yeah there's
this stereotype of English food being
bland yeah whereas I feel like Austin
acts like I'm not blind
not at all most of the snacks swaps I've
done before the taste isn't as intense
as America is I think brings one of the
first one where it's like pow ho I would
say that like this has been a great
experience in terms of remembering like
the things I loved about England it's
not persuaded me that American snacks
are better than English max I'm afraid
some people do things better than others
and that's the English way I guess I can
let a true Brit
[Music]